[Music]
it's godzilla
finally we are going to see this epic
showdown between godzilla
and kong i think people are waiting for
this fans have been waiting for this for
a really long time
they're gonna have to wait a little bit
longer to see what happens i wanted to
ask you
i know you like reality tv if
congress were on love island who would
actually do better i can't i was
watching love island last night this is
crazy
do you want to say like who would find a
girlfriend
yes i think kong i think
kong is like let me tell you how i feel
and godzilla's like no my man don't talk
to me
you know and and no no girl likes that
you know no girl
you know i mean maybe you do but i don't
so i think
that kong is more emotional and he's
going to tell you how he feels
i think kong is going to win love island
2021.
but dude but do girls like that because
sometimes the good guy the nice guy he
has those puppy dog eyes you know
he's eight guys you never stay away like
mad
good people that's what we need good
people i don't think that zilla's bad i
just think that he's just gonna be hard
at expressing his emotions
and we don't want that we want people
that are put together
i mean mom's just misunderstood
okay i'm going to take this a step
further okay who would you rather
because i know henry cavill said that
you
and him do tick tock videos when you did
an ola home
who would you rather do make a tick tock
video with because or kong
so zilla has quite short hands
and so doing this and this and this
gonna be quite difficult for him i feel
like
um throwing it back it's gonna be hard
for him so i would say
i would say kong kong would do better
okay you'd rather do the dance moves
with kong yeah
kong kong feels bad to me i feel like he
can be like
yeah i think that'll be cool oh my gosh
i still want to keep going down the
reality show me too honestly this is the
this is the best
what are you putting on keeping up with
the kardashians i'll just ask you that
one right okay
um um i think i think
kong again he's quite emotional i feel
like he's kind of dramatic
so we'd love that for him
okay talking about the movie now you are
you are driving i'm calling it double
driving in this movie because you are
physically driving and i know you got
your driver's license even though you
probably shot this before but i'm sure
assuming you were on a truck
um on built or whatever but you're also
the driving force in this movie
like literally and figuratively you are
the driving of team zilla so i wanted
you to talk a little bit about
that sort of leading the charge and how
you've evolved as an actress as a person
and as a character since the last one i
was definitely
a huge part of the film but we had so
many other driving forces that were on
different missions and
it's kind of like a well-oiled machine
um
right madison is definitely on her own
journey and she's found herself more
within the years that we have you know
seen her um she's found herself a bit
more she's older
you know she knows what she wants and
she embodies a lot of what her mother
believed in
um so i feel like
going from 14 to
no sorry going from 13 to 15
um a lot changes when you're younger i
feel like and i feel like
when within those two years i had been
i've
grown my hair down to here i dyed it
black and was like
yeah you know um so i went through that
stage so she did
she went through that stage my mom was
like i was like it's fine mum
it is a face um and so we did that and i
got to
kind of take that black hair and that
vibe
with me over to this film which was
actually kind of exciting because when i
had first spoken to the director i said
you know i'm going to the stage
where i want black hair i want piercings
and um i just i i want bracelets i want
a lot of jewelry and he was like great
like you just do it and i was like great
so what i did was i
um dyed my hair for the for the roll i
got i had
seven piercings in my ears because
that's just the space i went through
and uh and you know when i got to choose
my outfit i got to wear really cool
jewelry for the film and
painted my nails army green and i just
kind of went through the stage so
i love that that's what we really
embodied in this film it's like that
coming of age everybody goes through
stages like that and that's kind of the
stage that madison was in
and it was authentic to you it really
felt like it was authentic to me yeah
yeah that's what i wanted to do at that
time now i can't get over
pink same
always um you brian and julian have such
a great dynamic
and i feel like every film you work on
you always have such a good crew
and you i always feel like you really
bond with your cast mates you really
feel that energy you really felt it in
this one
so if you can talk about just that crew
and that experience and
how would the blooper reel on this
compared to like other blooper reels
that you've done well of festival
i mean i think it's so important to
to connect with your cast first and
foremost second of all
connect with your crew like your literal
crew that are filming you every day
um for me i am so always so close to the
camera department to the grips
to the catering i mean catering
specifically because they're feeding me
and then and you know i have i love
bonding with my crew and i had that
experience
with the hawaii set and then i got to
meet a whole different set of people
in australia so i loved that but talking
about the cast for a second
uh when meeting julian he was such a
warm person
somebody who you know immediately opened
himself up to me and was just like
let's be best friends i was like okay
this is great because now we're going to
get to work together and we can kind of
show that on screen and so we've created
such a strong friendship and we focused
very much on hanging out
outside of work so we just got to know
each other which was really nice
and then working with some of the older
actors it was great because you know
i've been in this industry for a while i
kind of grew up a little bit
uh faster than a regular kid so i got to
bring out the child and brian tyree
um which is amazing um and there is a
child within there
you know i was we i got him doing take
chocolate dances quite a bit
um and so uh it was really it was really
nice to be able to bond with my cast
just because i feel like that stuff
really does show on screen there is
something provoking him that we're not
seeing here
the same opinion i spoke to millie
yesterday and i talked
to her out both of you because i thought
you all had such a nice rapport on
screen
i saw julian your instagram you said you
were honolulu hippies together
so i asked her about both would you like
to know what she said
please tell us okay so
she said that the second she met you you
were very open you bonded immediately
and then brian she's brought out your
inner child and taught you to tick-tock
is this true
yes she also she also taught us how to
bark did she tell you that she barked on
set all the time because i'm going to
tell you she loved the book
yeah no she was so so she was i need to
see receipts on it
yeah i mean footage somewhere no it was
fun because
like we i mean you know our team is
together through this so we're going on
this
whole adventure like i would call this
team goonies sometimes just because it
felt like we were
you know going through this whole thing
together
and then here i am this grown black man
traveling with these two teenagers
trying to save the world and trying to
make like
hang on to what's left of my sanity uh
and it just was
it it was more fun than i thought it was
really fun it turned out
because i don't know if you know i'm
actually like 18 years old and so like i
was able to like really relate to
the two of them um and be their mentor
and their
guide you know what i mean and start
trying to uh i can relate to feelings
you know what i mean no i said i am 18 i
don't feel 18 i'm actually 18. oh okay
well i won't claim to be 18. did you
learn tick tock though was this a real
thing
at that time when we were filming it was
just coming about like for me like
because i still don't really understand
it like i still don't you know i'm not a
big
i used to be on social media but i'm not
a big social media person like that
anymore but
uh i would always try to duck and dodge
her tickles like
[ __ ] you'd be eating you could be
stuffing your face with fries and all of
a sudden
there you are it's like millie like
okay julian who would you rather tic
talk with kong or zilla who would
who would be better honestly i would
love to see them do
checks off i don't know if legendary
warner brothers is going to do that but
because he actually has arms um they're
not small
arms they're just conscious um
but not probably calm but as well she
would like bake cakes especially
when um honolulu every day because she
had um
like she was like what am i gonna do and
she would bake a cake every afternoon
after coming off set and it was way too
much cake i want to do a movie with
millie bobby brown
okay you're gonna take this a little bit
further to do kong vs zillow reality
show edition who would win on dancing
with the stars kong or zillow
i feel like godzilla's tail would just
hit everything i feel like yeah i was
going to say i was like
godzilla doesn't seem to have great hand
eye coordination you know what i mean
like i don't think and also godzilla's
arms are so small how is he going to
take home the
the the crystal ball what is it what's
the ball that they carry the
the trophy the mirror ball the mirror
ball so how i don't think
i don't think i don't think godzilla's
about that i think kong would be really
i would also like to see kong do the
pasta double a
like that to me would be
true artistry if we got to see kong up
there with
like doing the pasta double with cheryl
burke that would be amazing i want to
see
i'll zilla do the quick step that's what
i want to see
um i i really i wish i had more time i
don't have much time
but um brian i just wanted to ask you
really quick working with chloe zhao
she's an amazing award season how it was
to be a superhero eternals
just a little you know what to say about
it let's see it's coming out later this
year chloe working with chloe was
absolutely amazing i'm really really
proud of her for
the work that she's getting recognized
for and if you think that's something
just wait
until the turtles drops because she
actually is just one of the most amazing
visionaries i had the luxury to work
with
second to adam wingard adam we love you
i'm not trying to say
that you're less or more than chloe uh
but also just i'm just really happy for
her and eternals is going to be
just as epic so yeah
we need kong the world needs him so i
know everybody wants to know
everybody can find out who's going to
win this ultimate battle between kong
and zilla but
we want to ask you won't be me
we want to ask you if congler were to
compete on dancing with the stars
who would win i mean i would probably
say
kong because he's he's quite flexible
and nimble
uh i would rather watch
godzilla on the dance floor with those
stubby little legs um
something that i really enjoy i would
really enjoy that but ultimately i think
kong would
um i'm sure kong is a great
you know he you know he can move that
guy for sure
he's got the charisma but i feel like
godzilla would have more hip action
you really he's so stiff though isn't he
maybe arms and legs
yeah but like he can he can really move
i feel like godzilla well actually when
he's in
in in underwater he can really move
right
it's more on land so if it's like a
dance competition in water
100 godzilla but if it's like and making
that tail around
well that's true that's true well
i think we have a concept for the sequel
here it's a dance off
we drew we do both gameplay
we're dancers we're not fighters
we're lovers not fighters um so
by your words you've said that the last
couple of performances you know big
little lies
the last few things that you've done
have been a little bit more several
very dramatic internal this is very
dramatic but in a very
over-the-top sense is there any risk do
you ever check yourself as an actor and
go can i go too big can i
chew this seem too much or does it kind
of feel the same as doing a dramatic
role
no i to me it was quite cathartic
this experience i need i i hadn't done a
big
event tentpole movie since tarzan which
was five years ago
and like i said it it's been mostly on
more smaller character-driven pieces
slightly more you know and and quite
heavy um
subject matters like domestic abuse on
big little lies or the conflict in the
middle east on
little drummer girl so i was itching to
go and do something crazy and
big and wild and fun and unpretentious
and
um and and again i knew adam wenger the
filmmaker
uh and i he's i love him he's great
fantastic filmmaker but also like a
lovely guy
so i felt like the thought of going away
for six months with adam to great fun
locations in hawaii in australia
and just like again it was almost a
cathartic experience to kind of let go
and
and and and just have fun and go crazy
and then again like occasionally i
probably had too much fun and adam had
to kind of
pull me back a bit so but that's what
you have a great director for you know
i've i've heard that you're sort of a
fan of indiana jones and some of the
classic movies and this is such a
classic these are
two of them iconic movie characters in
history did you
have a geek out moment that i'm going to
be screaming with kong and zilla as much
as you've done in your career is there
sort of a geek out like
are you a fan of this and and this
franchise yeah i think from the first
date
like i stepped onto set i turned into a
six-year-old boy
like a six-year-old version of myself
because it was so surreal the whole
experience the
these gigantic sets and and also like to
stand there
and have a serious conversation with
adam about
like you said the two most iconic
creatures
in cinematic history kong and godzilla
and to stand there and actually like
have a conversation about it with a
filmmaker who's making a movie about
them was
uh i i couldn't believe it i couldn't
wrap my head around it it was so
so surreal so if there was if we could
take away all the cgi
the practical and we just saw we
isolated something that you did in this
movie what would be
like this ridiculous moment if they did
like a release
release you know something that you
would just look ridiculous
but with the added benefit of special
effects it looked
great home well i think even with
special effects there are plenty of
moments where i look ridiculous in the
movie
um i think the whole sequence of uh when
we're in the heave the the
the the subterranean spaceship there
um they they had that thing on a gimbal
so it was basically like a roller
coaster and they would like
tilt that and drop it and you know was
as crazy and wild as it looks when you
watched the movie so it was like
zero acting there we were all just
screaming
and almost crying so um that was a
pretty wild expectation
did anybody get sick who got nauseous uh
yes someone did i'm not gonna
name any names but it it did happen yeah
is it like being for a friend was it you
it wasn't you
uh no
no but i can't say but it there
yeah uh so dissolved the ultimate sort
of showdown between these two characters
people have really waited for
is an ultimate movie showdown between
two movies like either classic movies or
recent movies that you would like to see
of this
well someone earlier mentioned uh tarzan
versus kong uh
in an interview yesterday and i thought
that was quite interesting
uh but then i realized that i think they
would
get along really well i think they'd be
pals kong and tarzan because they're
both like
if you leave kong alone in the jungle
he's pretty happy-go-lucky and just kind
of chill
and so is tarzan so i don't i don't
think it's a great
pitch for to the studio like it's
basically two hours of kang and tarzan
just
chilling in the jungle just hanging out
eating some bananas
like yo uh so maybe not that fun to
watch because i definitely don't think
they would fight
but i would really enjoy making that
movie but
no one would watch it when you know
you're dancing it'd be like dancing with
the stars you'd get along too well
i think so i think that's there's
there's no tension whatsoever there
uh i was thinking it could be klein
versus kong like decline
she would go toe-to-toe with kong in a
big way
from big little eyes she'd be amazing um
really random cheesy question but you
know costuming plays such a big part
and for whatever reason your sunglasses
really stood out to me like it was such
a character it really was very character
defining was this just a random thing or
were the 40 pairs of sunglasses you
tried on before you guys arrived at
it was there any significance to it
because
for whatever reason it was a fantastic
choice well the whole
uh i think the sunglasses are a bit more
70s than 80s but
other than uh the look i was going for
was
marty mcfly from back to the future
nathan my character was
um uh i like that that
that he was like a huge star of he loved
80s you know fun action movies like back
to the future or uh
lethal weapon so i wanted uh so you know
the puffer
the puffer vest and the kind of uh the
you know the the stonewash denims and
all that so it was
the whole look was was uh inspired by
by michael j fox's character
that's really cool except much yeah the
glasses
again i think the glasses are a bit more
70s but um
yeah i i remember we probably we did
probably try 40 pairs
of glasses on but like they they were
just too cool
she had nowhere to go so i made a
promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
so i know this from interviewing you
before your name in real life means
angel and devil demon demon and angel
yes
demon even an angel so are you a demon
or an angel a movie that's you know um
i think we're we're both you know human
being
that's that's who we are you know we're
both sometimes
the demon in us you know comes out
like more presently like constantly
and then things go crazy right but
sometimes
angels dominate the day and the actions
and everything i think we have both and
i
you know that's pretty much how i choose
my characters when i see a character
that is human
you know i believe in human beings not
in you know villains or
or heroes or good guys or bad guys you
know to me it's about
both so when i from from what i know you
you have such a big personality and
you've been doing
you do such amazing dramatic roles
this felt to me like when i watched you
in it
oh yes because it's like a very big
performance he's a big character
how a departure did this feel like for
you from the stuff that you've been
doing more recently
uh you know i that's pretty much what we
love you know
we actors are always looking for
opportunities to
go from one extreme to another you know
and hopefully
to land roles that
uh demand different things from us
and that's pretty much how i choose my
projects you know i
i i try to go into opposite directions
and uh and yes you're right in the last
you know four films that we've been
premiering over the last you know five
months
there's a vast variety of different
characters that are there it's just a
joy to play you know
it's a gift when you have that as an
actor and then if that
if that beautiful character is a part of
a beautiful franchise like godzilla
kong then that's that's even better you
know that's that's a that's a gift
i heard you say something about how you
went from doing like you did land you
did midnight sky
but they think you did like a very small
budget movie in mexico
so have it how is it going from like the
smallest budget you've run
to something like this like what's the
biggest perk when you get upset oh
good we're just gone were you like can i
have coffee like what was it
yeah well see how making fails is the
same monster
never better said you know no pun
intended
uh it's the same monster anywhere you
know it's a universal thing
it's uh so when we make a film it's the
same thing to make it here or in bolivia
or argentina or mexico anywhere in the
world
the only thing that that changes is the
budget you can see the difference
between the
maybe on the catering but again you know
the film i did in mexico was the lowest
film i've ever made
and we ate like emperors you know like
oh my god
it's delicious
wow wonderful town beautiful people
great food
uh so you know it's the same thing and
uh i
i have been doing that you know jumping
from one budget to another
and uh and we we just keep swimming like
you know fishing a tank
well fishing an ocean better it's a
great godzilla pun
um so everybody obviously wants to know
who's going to win
the big matchup between godzilla and
kong but i'm going to put
to a different test we're going to put
godzilla and kong in a couple reality
shows tell me who's going to win
okay i'm not a big reality great
consumer though but i'll try which is
why you're going to give
the greatest most real spontaneous
answer
um the great british bake off who would
win between godzilla and king kong
in the great british bake off i will go
for godzilla
only because he has a great you know
oven
uh a great broil coming up over his
mouth right it's like an instant winner
right there right
it's like when you torch the dessert or
whatever they do
put on the plate let's go yeah oh my god
i feel like you should just drop the mic
on that ones too right
um okay dancing with the stars who is
winning on dancing with the stars
with dylan kong have you seen kong's
moves
have you seen kong's moves because that
says it all you know i mean
that guy can move he swings and he you
know
he's very slave and he takes it easy and
he
just goes with the flow and the music
and all that
that's that's that's he's a winner just
in general like i don't know how big a
fan
you were of this franchise history of
godzilla
and kong but but were you and also
why do you why are we still so
fascinated with these characters and
like was it so cool for you was there
like a fanboy moment we were like oh my
gosh this is so cool being in a movie
with these two icon icons
totally i i grew up watching these films
you weren't even in plans
you weren't even here when that happened
you know when we used to watch those
films where
they were made frame by frame you know
so weird and uh i love those films and i
always
i was fascinated by the possibility of
the impossible
i think that's why we are so we love
this film so much because
especially now with the technology
cgi and all that the way they do it it's
like you can actually
feel and touch the you know
stir uh you can you can
force almost you know and see their eyes
there's there's something there
there's soul in kung's eyes and uh
i i think it's fascinating because uh it
looks so real
especially nowadays that is just it's
beautiful to
to be able to imagine something like
that
so i know you've talked a little bit
about this but
this was very comedic i haven't seen you
be
comedic before in this way um was that a
choice
was that written in the script or did
you go here's what i want to do with
this character
no i mean it was it was definitely a um
it's a collaboration you can never take
full you know credit about these things
because
it's a vision of a director it's a
vision sort of a writer
i did feel like it was important to make
her
um not a stereotypical version of like
what a villain would be
and it's easy to fall into that
stereotype with that character because
at the end of the day it's a it's a
large cast and it's an ensemble it's not
like you're having
an independent moment for yourself to
really establish a personality
but i felt like it had it gave
an a permission for her to be like
condescending and fun and
sort of sloppy and i wanted to play with
it i mean even little moments like
when she trips and when she stands up
and she's so confused and scared like i
wanted her to feel like a real person
who like
obviously has an agenda but at the same
time doesn't
shy away from being a human being and
being scared and confused about the
whole situation
it was it was a grace it felt very
grounded i loved it i thought you were
wonderful in it um
so everybody's waiting for this mash-up
between these two titans
but what we wanted to do was put the two
titans in the reality show scenario and
you tell me who would win
oh my gosh so if we were
if kong and godzilla were going to
compete
on the great-ish bake-off my favorite
show
it's my favorite really my favorite show
my favorite show
watch every season
who would win i would i would say i
don't know
godzilla has really small hands like can
you imagine him trying to get it out of
the oven
it could be possible he'd be like
damn it i can't do but then godzilla
would not be able to put his hand
maybe he would use like a finger i think
maybe but the
the detailing of the big british bake
off like he would not be able to do
maybe godzilla i would say godzilla
because he has small little
fingers so he could do really really
intricate little details on the cakes
so godzilla so cute i feel like kong
would eat all the cake batter before he
even put it yeah he'd be like
like the cake would be just an explosion
that's what it'd be you just reminded me
with that sound effect
when you're on set what is like the most
ridiculous things
whether it's somebody making a sound
effect to sound like kong or if we like
didn't
put this guy in what's like the most
ridiculous thing you got to do
adam wingard would like express to us a
lot with noises like he's like okay and
then kong goes
and if we were like okay we we get it
like
are you wanting to do this or you're
just enjoying it it was just really fun
i mean it's like
it was such a we did and then just the
way that we would
he would describe the different type of
growls because we had to understand he's
like
this is a specific growl or this is a
growl about being sad
or whatever it was so it was always
really funny because it was different
growls throughout the script um
and we just laugh it was just so it was
like what are we do
what is this um but it was really fun
it's it's nice it's like being a child
again it's like would you
with this i'm thinking to myself would
this ever be useful in life knowing
different grounds
or is this something that maybe i
wouldn't put it past
you like you never know you know at this
point it's like i'll take anything
learning how to grow perfect i got it
so this is obviously a great mashup
between two titans we want to know from
you
if you could mash up two movies any two
movies and have them go verses
what would be your dress up oh whoa
it definitely definitely would involve
kill bill so it'd be like
kill bill and oh
that's a hard one
i would do kill bill i'll go more action
like i would put
kill bill with maybe
die hard cast yourself in it and what
side are you playing on
exactly i would be in kill bill
i could see i i could honestly or like a
reboot so you doing something like that
that would be amazing hi quentin
tarantino
you've been in so many big block films
but was there
at all kind of this feeling of oh my
gosh this is godzilla thinking these are
like almost hundred-year-old characters
was there a geek out moment for you
absolutely it never it never you know
gets
old it always is like first of all the
fact that we were able to be in a
godzilla
and a king kong movie in one it was like
two birds with one stone this is awesome
and then secondly
i guess that you know it you're always
pinching yourself when you're making
movies period and let alone when
i think i grew up in mexico city just
like dreaming of being an actress and
never did i
ever ever in my life ex imagine that
you know because for me growing up that
was not a possibility it's not something
that i saw on screen i didn't see that a
lot i didn't see latina women
in big franchises like this um it was
really really really really really rare
to just see latino women in screen
big screen period end so the fact that i
was able to be part of such an iconic
franchise and it has such a
you know huge fan base and and
especially they're big in mexico people
are obsessed with them in mexico so i
just felt very
honored and grateful and grateful for
the production team and and the director
for trusting me and making me part of it
because
that's honestly a a real important thing
that
the team did you know legendary warner
uh adam by supporting a very
big cast with all colors and skins and
backgrounds and not really making it
about where they're from
but most importantly just making sure
that they represented the real world on
screen it felt contemporary it felt real
the female characters didn't feel like
um
like a stereotypical damsel in distress
on the contrary
all the female characters are so crucial
to the film so
it felt like i was really honored to be
part of such a
a progressive in a sense film and really
a new age and a rebirth of filmmaking
for women as well
and for diversity so i felt very happy
that this movie will be
showing that worldwide and i love that
it's also really
young women too it's like you have
kaylee and you and milly it's
it's like such a great message to not
just have one but have several
young females that yeah
that and something that i was talking
about with damien who's like having two
mexicans in one movie like
you know there's something that always
becomes a kind of a conversation where
like
you know oh they cast it already in
mexicans they're not gonna cast two
latinos or that's something that
really happens to us and the fact that
that wasn't a thought and it was like
yeah there's gonna be two
two mexican people and it's gonna be
fine and it's not gonna be a thing and
it's gonna be
natural and organic and also they're not
a stereotypical version of what we
look at uh when we see mexican
characters portrayed in big screens
it was it was a gift the whole movie was
a gift i am grateful
i'm so happy i also love it i think the
audiences are gonna like it so
i hope they get to see it on the big
screen too
[Music]
and this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
both of your performances really felt to
me the heart
of the movie there's so much big action
but these films always have to have a
heart
so i'll start with you kaylee and ask
you how did you create
there was such a soul from your
performance how did you create such
a bond with the character that wasn't
there
i just imagined that he was there um
with reading the script and reading the
emotions and
you know i i believed he was there so
much of that is i think is due to a
young person's imagination
and rebecca i wanted to ask you had you
signed before
and how did you and kaylee create that
bond on set because i really
felt that you had a history that you
really had that relationship
no i'd never i'd had didn't know any asl
prior to this
and i feel very um
grateful that i know some now because it
really is quite a beautiful language and
i i learned so much about it so
so many so many sort of dumb
preconceptions that i had like i thought
it was all about your hand movements and
actually
so much of it is about expression and
face and which is
not dissimilar to what i do as an actor
um as to the
bond that you see on the screen between
kelly and
i i think it i think it just comes from
the fact that we spent a lot of time
together on set
and she was teaching me asl throughout
the filming either her or her father or
a couple of other people um and so you
know we we had
we had this relationship off screen as
well as on screen
and you know i really relied on her
enormously
and she's also really fun to hang out
with she's very funny um
as well as being a brilliant actor she's
just like nothing
more too and you got to go to some
pretty cool locations hawaii and hang
some amazing locations
um and i think over the years we've seen
kong
before with people but he connects with
you kaylee on
in a different way than we have before
so why is that important for you and
what do you hope audiences will learn
and take away from it
without that connection kong wouldn't be
able to get to his home safely and he
you know it might have been the end for
kong so
if somebody that was able to communicate
with him like gio was
it was able to bring him home safely and
supporting kong i feel like it made him
happier to want to go home and be safe
i just wanted to follow up and ask if
this is kaylie's first movie because i
looked and i and i don't see another
film
on her um resume page so it was first
film
and how did she get this was this role
time yes
i was actually contacted contacted
through social media
i was involved in another short film and
they
that film led them to finding me until
now you reminded me
of a young diana prince aka wonder woman
wondering if there's a a film like that
that you would like to do in the future
if there's a troll oh yeah i want to be
involved in something like that
[Laughter]
um why do you think and this is a
question for you rebecca
why do you think that these characters
endured for almost
like 100 years they've been around for
so long
it's a combination of spectacle um
grandeur
and i i think you know it's possible to
project a lot of
fears onto these kind of mythical
monster figures
but also projects a lot of you know
human emotion onto them too and so i
guess it's a way of like
dealing with certain stuff you know they
can become metaphors for all sorts of
things and
you know so we can keep using them for
whatever way that we need to express
whatever's going on with us
so i you know they're not going away
away anytime soon because of that
well i think everybody is waiting to see
this epic
match up between these two characters
having them face off but we wanted to
ask
both of you how you think that kongzilla
would do on some reality shows
so first we want to ask who think would
win
on dancing with the stars would it be
king kong or godzilla
you know i i think i have to say what
did you say katie
instantly kong um yeah i'm actually i'm
gonna be controversial i'm going with
godzilla on this one
because he's got the lights you know
he's got a bit more pizzazz
he's gonna get to do i mean imagine if
he starts using the light and the stuff
to be all like you know do a big ending
it would be epic no one has brought that
up yet
that's very true why haley did you say
kong
why
because in the movie he's grabbing on to
a lot of things that kind of you know he
has the moves it looks like to me
he's got the moves he's got soul
yes okay how about the grish baking show
who would win on great british speaking
show i can't even know what that is
um i think i've heard i don't think i've
heard of that one yet
i know what it is i've watched every
secret
yeah rebecca you'll let you take it and
then you can um
tell kaylee what it is and then she can
shoot it's like you know it's where
people have to compete to bake the best
thing whatever it is like a cake or
whatever
okay i get the concept but i i haven't
seen it maybe i haven't seen the british
version but i have seen like american
versions yeah that's like other
there's other american versions of it um
i would say again
godzilla again i know this is
controversial but
the flame stuff it's going to help him
if there's like a
you know if there's like a creme brulee
off he's going to be really fast with
that
he's going to be pushing he can do all
the you know
um kaylee's choice
i'd probably yeah i'd probably have to
go with godzilla as well
okay i'll give you one more real quick
key the kardashians
who would do better on that show
you got to be strong you got to be very
strong
uh kong i'm going kong this time
what about you kelly kong
you know he has a history with women so
of meeting women's and babies
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
first actually i have a little um a
little in question for you
um tell me about this kaiju club text
chain
yeah well uh that kind of started by i
think it was probably
jordan vote roberts because he he's
really sort of the ring leader of that
of that whole group he's
the director of kong skull island and so
oh and they told me about it
yeah of course of course he is and um
you know and also i should mention like
like the second that i it was announced
that i was going to do this film
jordan was the first person to reach out
to me and he said
all right man we're gonna we gotta go
and get dinner i gotta give you the
lowdown of what doing one of these
movies is like and all this stuff and
you know and and we've been friends
since and um yeah so
the kaiju club thing is you know it's me
mike doherty
um jordan boat roberts and uh gareth
edwards
and we're on a text chain and you know
like sometimes it's just them razzing me
because i'm the one
i'm the new fish you know like so i'm
the odd one out and so they kind of give
me a hard time sometimes
other times it's just everybody's just
kind of like chatting about just
whatever
like just the other day i remember um
you know
uh mike doherty uh actually i shouldn't
say this because
you know that's the funny thing about
the the kaiju club
is that it's very kind of there's a lot
of like personal fun
information but um you know it's like
i'm always tempted to like kind of like
uh like screenshot it to share with
people but i'm like
well i don't know if they want them to
know because like sometimes you'll know
where to find us
you know at very particular times and i
don't want to like have like for
instance like
i don't want to get like mike doherty a
stalker or anything
well he said jordan told me it was
almost like a therapy sesh
in some senses like when you're going
through it's such a huge undertaking
it is yeah i mean you know it doing a
big movie like this can be a little
traumatic at times i mean you spend
years of your life and
um there's there's ups and downs with it
you know sometimes it feels like it's
never going to work out
you know some days it's going great and
so sometimes you just need
you know to vent and you know and and
they've been really helpful in that
regard so along those lines
knowing that pop skull was made for two
thousand dollars
it was your second film award-winning
home but two grand
going from that to a 200 million dollar
budget
in time but was there something back
then that you said to yourself as a
you know an earlier filmmaker if i only
had the budget i would do this that you
got to do on this movie
well you know the funny thing is is that
you you say that on every movie i mean
even on a big movie like this you're
constantly saying
like if we if we just had you know 15
more million dollars
all of our problems would be over
because you know it doesn't matter what
budget level you're at you're constantly
your your film is always more ambitious
than what you have the money for so on
popsicle
you know it was always like if we just
had ten thousand dollars we could just
have whatever we wanted you know we're
on your next
if we just had one more million dollars
you know out of our million dollar
budget
you know we could we would have zero
problems
um and you always feel that way but
everything always upscales and you know
and and so you there's never a perfect
budget that i don't think anybody's ever
been like
okay you know like here's my here's my
script and this is the money
i mean you know maybe james cameron has
that i don't know but like
not you know that it's just one of those
things where you're always
and and you have to be that way as a
filmmaker you have to your ambition
always has to be bigger and bigger
you know it's totally a metaphor for
life though we're never satisfied are we
we always want that a little bit more
and then we get a little bit more
everybody has been debating for so many
years it's one of the biggest movie
debates
who's going to win between godzilla and
kong but i want to know for
you internally what was like one or
biggest debate or what are your big
debates
in terms of creating i heard something
about the size of godzilla's head you'd
maybe debate that
but what was your biggest internal
debate as you were creating this film
you know i i think like for me it was
like the
you know all the the the technical
things
weren't really ever a problem you know
like the actual fights
you know they kind of were always
working themselves out there was a lot
of logistical things within the scripts
that were an issue i mean this is a
movie that's that's uh
just under two hours but we fit a lot in
two hours we go all over the world
in the world you know like we we go all
over the place and so
there's just like logistical issues
because you need your characters to get
here to here
and then here and then back over here
and you need to do it in a way that
doesn't feel forced and
you know and and still has the weight of
you know the experience and um
so that was probably the biggest kind of
challenge that i kind of wrestled with
was
you know just nailing aspects of the
script and um
uh and and you know and you always hear
stories on
big hollywood movies about scripts being
written
you know still while they're shooting
and you know um
and you get all the drafts and it's only
when you're actually
in the process of making one of these
things that you that you can kind of
like fully wrap your head around it i
couldn't possibly explain to you that
process
because it's one that's so stretched out
and kind of incomprehensible
but it's just like in the end
it almost feels like a miracle you know
cause like i step back and i look at the
film and i'm like the
the movie turned out even better than i
even imagined and i had my expectations
were through the roof
so um i couldn't be more pleased with it
but
how we got here is just it's it's a
mystical journey in some ways are there
um for fans are there easter eggs people
can look out for and i know that there's
a pops
like homage in there is there but there
are easter eggs as well in this film
uh yeah i mean there's there's lots of
easter eggs you know some referring to
the directly to king kong versus
godzilla the original 1960s film
but then there's a lot of easter eggs
which you can kind of see some of them
in the trailer
you know there's a lot of 80s action you
know
uh and early 90s action things like some
direct die-hard references
lethal weapon to two um and uh
and then of course jaws those are some
of the more obvious ones
um you know that's the fun thing about
easter eggs is that you know
it it'll be fun for people to to check
them out and find them but
of course there's like tons of them in
there and you know and the thing about
vfx nowadays is that
you can hide so many interesting little
things because
you have to create all these like
intricate details and so
um not only am i putting lots of stuff
in there but
you know occasionally i still find
things that the vfx artists are putting
in there that like
maybe like for instance i i've only seen
like on the imax version where you're
like oh i never noticed that little
thing in the tiny corner over here you
know even after all the vfx reviews and
all that kind of stuff that we did um so
it's it's pretty interesting for even
for me i mean i even find easter eggs
well i'm hoping that we're going to see
uh like a four-hour director's cut
one day for this film but this is going
to be the firm that a lot of people see
in theaters
after the you know not being in theaters
for a long time so what does that mean
to you
this is the perfect movie to see on the
big i mean
the bigger screen possible as far as
i've learned yeah absolutely i mean
you know it it literally doesn't get any
bigger than this with these two icons so
um you know we we made the movie you
know with
with the theatrical experience in mind
and then the world changed and
you know now there's a you know a bit of
a compromise where
you know you can still watch on hbo max
if you're you know
um still kind of in the midst of the
pandemic but
really at the end of the day it's like
this is a film that you know we're
hoping will kind of
reinvigorate cinemas and get people
going back to the movies
um you know it's you know i don't know
what what
what this you know theatrical success
uh would be considered nowadays i mean i
think the bar is relatively low in terms
of the box office
um but i you know i really hope that
like we can get people in there because
i i think that they'll have a really
magical experience i'm not gonna lie
i've been
looking at the amc theaters here in l.a
now that the theaters are opening and
i've been tracking like you know um
you know if uh if those screenings are
you know filling up and
and they're starting to sell out really
well even weeks in advance so
i'm very very excited and you know i i'm
also going to like
i plan once the movie comes out i'm
going to go and
get some tickets and i'm going to
discreetly sit in the back of the
theater and
and watch crowds watch it because um you
know i just haven't had that experience
yet we did we
we did one test screening before the
pandemic and uh
and and it went really well but like we
we haven't done
another one since so i haven't really
seen it with the audience very many
times so i'm very very excited this is
an audience movie so
um that's the experience i'm really
looking forward to the most and have
been since the beginning
kong bows to no one
[Music]
you